- Ich weiß nicht, ob ich gut genug bin.
- Keine falsche Bescheidenheit,
Bruderherz!
Du sprichst großartig.
Du kannst die Regeln.
Sei einfach entspannt.
- Hey, Pepe.
- Hi!
- Äh du, ich weiß, ihr lernt gerade für
die Sprachprüfung. Aber
kannst du vielleicht mal kurz
über meine Steuererklärung schauen?
Ich mach' das zum ersten Mal
und ich hab' da
noch nicht so die Gelassenheit.
- Ich komm' alleine klar.
- Bist du sicher?
- Ja.
- Dann helf' ich dir.
- Ach, vielen, vielen Dank! Jetzt hab'
ich ein bisschen Klarheit.
Ich wusste nicht, dass ich meine
Fahrtkosten für meine ehrenamtlichen
Tätigkeiten absetzen kann.
- Manchmal geht's, manchmal nicht.
Du solltest es aber
auf jeden Fall probieren.
- Mich wundert, wie du die ganzen
Sachen überhaupt schaffst.
- Mich auch.
- Machst du Sport?
- Ähm …
- Ähm. Ich meine,
wenn ich so viel zu tun hab',
dann brauch' ich immer
irgendeinen Ausgleich.
- Nein, tu ich nicht. Was machst du?
- Boxen. Das ist anstrengend und
man kann sich super abreagieren.
Aber das ist vielleicht nicht
das Richtige für dich.
- Also, um ehrlich zu sein,
wollte ich das schon
immer mal ausprobieren.
- Okay. Wann?
- Jetzt?
- Okay, dann gehen wir!
- Tschüss!